we're now going to take the California
Standards test Algebra one real used
questions the last series I had done the
algebra to them I guess I'm going in
reverse order let me copy and paste this
first question because I think it's good
to see the whole thing so let me see I
have copied it let me move this pointer
all the way up and then there we go
all right and they are asking us is the
equation three times 2x minus 4 equal to
minus 18 equivalent to 6x minus 12 is
equal to 18 so let's think about this if
we just distribute this 3 what we get 3
times 2x is 6x 3 times minus 4 is minus
12 and that of course is equal to minus
18 so sure they're the same thing if you
just distribute the 3 over the 2x minus
4 you get 6x minus 12 so the answer is
definitely yes there's no one down here
and it says yes the equivalents the
equations are equivalent by the
associative no communicative no the
equations are equivalent by the
distributive property there's a some
type of a firetruck going on outside
let's see where was I oh yes yes the
equations are equivalent by the
distributive property of multiplication
over addition right that's that we
distributed this three over the 2x minus
4 and they say over addition because you
could view this as a plus minus 4
addition and subtraction is really the
same thing when you think of the
distributive property anyway let's do
the next problem the next problem I can
just write out this is problem number
two they say the square root of 16 plus
the cube root of 8 is equal to what
what's the square root of 16 and when
you just have a square root that you
might say well maybe it's plus or minus
4 but when they write it this way means
the principal root so it's just plus 4
they would write a plus or minus out
front if they wanted you to get the
negative square root so it's 4 plus now
what do the 3rd power is equal to 8 well
2 to the 3rd power is equal to 8 right
so the cube root so we you know we could
write 2 to the third is equal to 8
that's the same
as saying the cube root of 8 is equal to
2 you can also view this as 8 to the 1/3
power
anyway the cube root of 8 is then 2 so 4
plus 2 is equal to 6 and that is choice
B problem 3 problem 3 let me scroll down
a little bit okay and they want to know
I can copy and paste the whole thing
there we go and they want to know which
expression is equivalent to X to the
sixth times x squared so X to the 6
times x squared you have the same base
when you're multiplying both of these
cards we can add the exponents so that
is equal to X to the 6 plus 2 is 8
that's not one of the choices here so we
have to say which of these also are the
same thing as X to the 8th and so which
two exponents when I add them is equal
to 8 4 plus 3 is equal 7 5 plus 3 this
is equal to X to the 8th as well so that
is choice B next problem problem 4 all
right they let me this another one where
I'll copy and paste it all right they
want to know which number does not have
a reciprocal so the reciprocal of
negative 1 that's just 1 over negative 1
which is equal to negative 1 the
reciprocal of 0 that's what 1 over is 0
which is not defined so the choice is B
0 we don't know what 1 over 0 is maybe
that's a project for you to think of it
what it should mean and of course these
have reciprocals 1 over 1 over a
thousand is just equal to 1 times 1,000
over 1 which is equal to a thousand and
the reciprocal of 3 is of course 1/3
next problem next problem
they say there's a lot of terminology
here but I guess that's good so they
want to know just copying maybe I'll do
the next one too
okay I could Pais do it up here alright
they want to know what is the
multiplicative inverse of 1/2 so
essentially what can I multiply 1/2 by
and then get 1 right so if I multiply
what 1 it's the same thing as saying
what's the inverse of 1/2 so if I
multiply 1/2 by well the inverse of 1/2
say 1 over 1/2 that's the same thing as
1 times 2 over 1 which is equal to 2 or
another way to think of it is 2 times
1/2 is equal to 1 so the multiplicative
inverse of 1/2 is just 2 and that's
choice D problem 6 what is the solution
for this equation alright sometimes
these absolute value signs can appear
daunting but you just have to think it
through logically if the absolute value
of 2x minus 3 is equal to 5 that tells
us what that means that 2x minus 3 is
equal to 5 right because if inside the
absolute value is equal to 5 then the
absolute value of 5 is equal to 5 so
that's fair enough
but what could 2x minus 3 also be equal
to what happens if 2x minus 3
within the absolute value sign is equal
to minus 5 well then you would take the
absolute value of that and you would get
5 right so 2x minus 3 could also be
equal to because also be equal to minus
5 all right when you see this absolute
value sign you say okay whatever is
inside the absolute value is either 5 or
negative 5 because we're taking the
absolute value of it to get 5 so we just
solve both of these equations if you add
3 to both sides of this 1 you get 2x is
equal to 8 X is equal to 4 on the second
one you add 3 to both sides you get 2x
is equal to minus 5 plus 3 is minus 2 X
is equal to minus 2 divided by 2 is
negative 1 so X could be equal to 4 or X
could be equal to negative 1 and that is
choice C X is negative 1 or X is
to for next problem the Algebra one ones
go faster than the algebra two problem
so it's tend to be hairier okay let me
clear all of this okay I'll just write
this one down they say what is the
solution set for the inequality five
minus the absolute value of x plus four
is less than or equal to minus three so
at first this is really daunting I can't
even make you know do that logic that I
did last time because I've been five out
there but let's think of this way let's
try to simplify it so we have you know
just the absolute value of something is
less than or equal to something else so
one thing we could do is if we want to
get rid of this five remember what we do
to both sides of equation or inequality
whatever we do to one side of an
equation or inequality or ending
equality we do the both sides so let's
subtract 5 from both sides of this
equation right if you subtract 5 from
the left side this 5 disappears right
I'm just going to do - let me write that
out - 5 + and I'm going to do a minus 5
there so my so plus that's a plus so
minus 5 plus 5 is zero so I'm just left
with - absolute value of x plus 4 is
less than or equal to now what's -3
minus 5 let's - 8 all right now this
next step this is something maybe it
wasn't obvious for you and it makes
putting the inequality there is you know
if this was an equality that you would
just say okay I'm going to multiply or
divide both sides by negative one to get
rid of the negative signs but one thing
you have to remember whenever you
multiply or divide both sides of an
inequality by a negative number you have
to switch the inequality so if this is
true then if I'm multiplying both sides
of this by negative one so negative one
times negative x plus four I'm going to
switch the inequalities the inequality
so that's going to become greater than
or equal to negative eight and I did the
negative one on this side so I have to
multiply it times negative one on that
and so this negative cancels out that
negative so we're just left with X plus
4 is greater than or equal to negative 8
times the negative 1 is equal to 8 now
we can just use the logic that we had
from that last problem this tells us
what this tells us that the magnitude of
X plus 4 is greater than or equal to 8
so magnitude I let me draw a number line
here because I really want you to get
the intuition of what magnitude means so
if that's the number line the number
line and you can view magnitude as kind
of the distance from or the absolute
values you can have you from the
distance from 0 right so this is 0 right
here and this is positive 8 and this is
minus 8 the absolute value of whatever
this quantity is is greater than 8 that
means its distance from 0 has to be
greater than 8 you could just say the
distance of 0 from 0 of this number has
to be greater than 8 so that means that
this number greater than or equal to 8
that means that this number is
definitely going to be greater than or
equal to positive 8 right on the number
line it would be all of those numbers
right or remember we're saying the
magnitude so we don't care about the
direction the magnitude is going to be
great has to be greater than positive 8
so it also includes the negative numbers
less than negative 8 and why does that
make sense well take negative 9 what's
the absolute value of negative 9 the
absolute value of negative 9 is greater
than 8 right it's because 9 is greater
than 8 so any number to the left of
negative 8 or to the right of positive 8
so what does that tell us about this
equation so that means that well the
easy one is X plus 4 could be greater
than or equal to 8 so let's write that
down let me write it here X plus 4
greater than or equal to 8 and that
takes into consideration that the
magnitude is greater than or equal to 8
there or X plus 4 less than or equal to
minus 8 right that's the magnitude to
the left of this
vade right there and now we solve it
it's very important to think of absolute
value in these terms otherwise you can
get become very confusing and you start
testing numbers but if you really just
visualize the number line and you think
of absolute value as distance from zero
magnitude of the distance from zero say
oh the distance from zero has to be
greater than or equal to eight
so that means my number has to be this
thing has to be less than or equal to
minus eight or it has to be greater than
or equal to positive eight so let's
solve X plus 4 is greater than or equal
to 8 subtract 4 from both sides so you
get X is greater than or equal to 4 I
just subtracted 4 from both sides
subtract 4 from both sides here you get
X is less than or equal to minus 12 so
the solution here is X is greater than
or equal to 4 or X is less than or equal
to minus 12 and that is choice D anyway
I'll see you in the next video